it's Fan Appreciation Month it's screen
junkies and her reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that
you voted for
here's your second-place choice
[Music]
from row all day all row I'll down from
creepy dr. Seuss comes a classic blend
of fairy tale horror film and two ounces
of shrooms Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory
experience a movie that's pure
children's wish fulfillment but still
wasn't afraid to scar you for life that
balanced out its joy and wonder with
lessons on how adults were mostly idiots
kids were mostly evil and even good guys
could freak out at any moment in the
secret test of your integrity
you lose good day sir
Candy's good trust is bad got it meet
Charlie a sweet boy reduced to poverty
because of his con artists Grandpa Joe a
swindler who takes money for smokes
while the rest of the family eats
cabbage water advocates child abuse what
she wants is a good kick in the pants
talks Charlie into stealing let's take a
break charlie nobody's watching has two
big coke nails and goes from bedridden
to dancing as soon as free chocolate
comes along we're on to you Grandpa Joe
we're on to you
the lady Walda shines as Willy Wonka the
Howard Hughes of diabetes he isn't just
a reclusive nutcase he's also a master
of sarcasm please
krazee-eyez and very likely a serial
killer too naughty nasty little children
gone three good sweet little children
laugh
watch as he turns a factory tour into a
deadly game where only the generous
survive while the impure are disfigured
in accordance with their sins and a cult
of tiny orange monsters dispose of the
bodies don't believe me there's no seat
on the boat for Augustus food Walken
knew what he was doing man he knew so
enjoy a film that will haunt and delight
you for a lifetime
unlike the Tim Burton version which will
probably just haunt you so experience a
classic film full of unforgettable music
and to help us remember
here's Michael Bolton wait did I read
that right
you mean multi Grammy Award winner
Michael Bolton hello epic voice guy whoa
what are you doing here you invited me
here well I'm sure we didn't think you'd
actually show up well I did because I
have a new album to promote and it's
called songs of cinema and whatever you
guys did with Deadpool it worked oh
thank you then let's do this featuring
the creepy man saw
[Music]
the creeping man can cuz he's got a wife
and with even more candy the dear God
please help us all and this place is a
lawsuit waiting to happen song
you fall in burn your skin
safety violations my factory has no
Galatians we don't really broke candy
right we just toss some shoes into it
every surface sounded a chocolate River
is mixed with soon
oh just go to start starring Johnny
death Joe Biden his time when senpai
notices you the lollipop guild 90s alt
rock band what obesity is to look like
and America saw four kids wow thanks for
that mr. Bolton no problem as long as
you call me back when you do the fifth
Captain Jack Sparrow movie oh they're
making a fifth one alright No
right I can't wait extra special thanks
to Michael Bolton whose newest album
songs of cinema is available on
frontieres' music go tell them thanks
for us by clicking the link below and
getting yourself a copy and if you want
to see a deleted song along with an
exclusive interview with michael click
the box to the left to watch our special
honest trailer commentary the execs two
superfans Franz H Duncan K and Helena M
for voting for this trailer and helping
to make Fan Appreciation Month tune in
next week to see your number one choice
we are the music makers and we are the
dreamers of dreams there's no earthly
way of knowing which direction we are
going teddy
I want an oompa-loompa now the
snozzberries taste like snozzberries
view grows you lose good day sir